you seem to be suggesting that you're
hoping that a Europe will offer reforms
and be that the British people will
accept those reforms and then decide
they don't want to brakes it and all
that to happen in what a few months yeah
but you know all of these things are
going to come to a head quite soon now
and the anxieties that the British have
which gave rise to to the Braves it vote
which I think Center to a significant
degree around issues of immigration
Europe's also got a big problem it's a
huge issue in Germany it's a huge issue
in France it's a determining issue in
Austria it's a big issue in the Italian
election now happening so all over
Europe this is a big problem so if
you're up smart about it then it
shouldn't treat the British anxiety over
immigration as if oh that's just the
Brits being unreasonable it should
realize there's a major problem for
Europe and there are reforms and changes
that Europe could propose that would
help deal with the British anxiety over
immigration but also deal with the
European wide act anxieties over
immigration Mr Cameron
tried that right so the two big
differences between now and two years
ago one frankly breaks it's happened and
Europe is also anxious about Briggs's
secondly and the immigration issues
within Europe are manifestly convulsing
the whole of European politics I mean
okay only Britain had the referendum on
Europe but actually this is a problem
all over Europe and thirdly it's obvious
that the things we need to do in order
to strengthen the controls around
immigration are things that were command
widespread support right across the
political spectrum so you know look
politics is in the end all about how you
try and find a reasonable solution to
big challenges and in my view we either
are going to go down the path of what
will increasingly be a very hard break
suit which is going to damage Britain
and damage Europe all we find a
different way forward what I honestly
believe is the worst of all worlds is we
kind of do a half in half out
we're we're abiding by some of the
European rules but not by others where
we have a mix of the European Court of
Justice and some other body where you
know we're we're neither one thing nor
the other
I honestly think in those circumstances
the British people will say let's decide
this we either go for this deal the
government's got or we decide to stay
you seem it you seem frustrated
you don't seem g'd up as though this is
possible in a way that perhaps you did a
few months ago is there an acceptance
that this is one heck of an uphill
battle that you answer yourself no
actually on the country I feel much more
upbeat about it than I do now than I did
a few months ago
I mean when a year ago I put the chances
of changing breaks it at about 25% a few
months ago before Christmas I would have
put it a 40% I I think it's now 50% I
think it's very hard to see how the
government wins the boat in the House of
Commons because the government at some
point is going to have to resolve the
dilemma they keep avoiding which is you
either to minimize economic damage state
close to Europe in which case you'll
have to abide by Europe's rules but
you'll have lost your seat at the
decision-making table or alternatively
because you prioritize getting rid of
those rules you will be in a situation
where you're going to do significant
economic damage there's no solution to
that dilemma it's not an it it's not a
dilemma you can negotiate around you're
gonna have to choose and once the
government makes that choice I think
they're gonna find it very hard to get
either of those propositions through the
House of Commons and you worry that you
know naturally you have baggage right
how much of a problem is that for your
cause now on brexit you're tainted in a
way that might switch people off and and
it might not help the cause that you're
on approach look the thing you learn
about modern politics is that everyone
has their controversies and difficulties
and you know I'm Briggs it it's a
divisive issue you know some people will
like what I said breaks it some people
hate it you know I took the decision a
long time ago on this issue that it's so
fundamentally important to the country
you know I was Prime Minister for ten
years I care about this country I don't
to see it make what I think is a really
historical mistake now other people may
profoundly disagree okay that's
democracy and I always say to people
think about democracy is I've got the
right to speak and you got the right to
listen but you don't have the right tell
me I can't speak and I don't have the
right to force you to listen and in the
end this is something that matters
people may be bored to hell about it but
I'm afraid it matters so much to the
future of this country that we've got to
face up to the consequences of it and
decide we're either going to break with
Europe in which case we're going to then
have to form a new future for the
country or alternatively to decide we're
gonna stay